well our position is that we want to
have a general election and syriza may
can't get the support of Parliament or
even her own party to push through
whichever Deal or No Deal as sue
suggested on Friday what what we have
said is that Jeremy was elected to
democratize the Labor Party and although
it's not our position policy wise if
members decided that this conference
that they wanted to have a people's vote
or a second referendum of course we'd
respect the membership so it's going to
be an interesting few days I think
Tuesday is the brexit debate so we're
watching closely
so what do you think do you want to see
us a comment I have reservations I would
prefer to push the government into a
general election for the reasons that
I've said I don't think Theresa May will
have got the respect or support of
Parliament or her own party or the
opposition if she can't get any deal
through and in that situation she's not
a credible government she can't take
things through she's not stable and we
should have a general oh no your
reservations about that in terms of the
people's vote if the government was in
power the current government that we've
got they would hold the pen on that
people's vote they would determine the
questions that will be asked in such of
people's vote they might be able to skew
it in particular directions to secure
the result that they wanted and I would
question the fairness of that but as I
said I mean ultimately if the reason I
can't get a deal through Parliament
should she really be the prime minister
I'm gonna guess the issue as well for a
peoples though is that in your
constituency these places like Salford a
lot of people will think that this is a
bit of a betrayal of what they voted for
well that's what I mean we're one of
those constituencies that voted leave by
kind of a slight margin where we had
lots of mixtures of opinion it wasn't a
binary choice for a lot of people there
was some food main is infirm leavers but
a lot of people in between and that's
what a second referendum you know causes
concern for me over because I think with
people like that that you know really
weren't sure and still aren't sure and
just want to get the best deal and make
sure that our economy is set off on the
right track it would be concerning for
them and I think you know depending on
how the referendum was set out it could
cause significant issues who do see
civil disobedience like Barry Gardner
suggested well I wouldn't well I mean I
wouldn't say civil disobedience but I
think people would find it quite
concerning
and I think it needs to be looked at
very carefully but as I say you know if
we've got a government in power that
can't secure the support of parliament
on something as fundamental as brexit
they really shouldn't be in power we
should have a general election to
determine the future of the country it's
pretty clear then that you would prefer
to see the general election rather than
the second my friend erm I'm keen to
talk to you about Labour's brexit
position because it's easy in a way to
blame to resume it's all her fault she's
the one who's messing everything up but
actually you have a responsibility as
well don't you as a lake party to put
forward a credible alternative to try
and shape the debate and the minute
you're saying you want to be in a
customs union within you but Theresa May
made it very clear this week that
actually the EU is only offering two
different options and if you want to be
in the customs union than the EU say you
have to be in the EI as well and that
you have to accept free movement of
people that is what she explicitly said
this week we'd still have to abide by
all the EU rules unquote controlled
immigration from the EU we wouldn't be
able to do trade deals and she's right
isn't she
Labour's position would mean
uncontrolled immigration from the no
let's be honest Tereza may set out on
these negotiations on completely the
wrong foot she's been quite polished
throughout she hasn't tried to win
friends and influence people the
European Union wants a good deal with
the UK because our two economies are
dependent upon each other and standing
you know as blatantly as you did on
Friday in stating that we will pursue a
No Deal if you don't do what we want is
not the approach that we take is the
reigning political game tonight you as
well let's take the rhetoric out of it
because the she was clear wasn't she and
we know it's true for what the EU has
said as well saying there will be no
chat cherry-picking in it there's two
options on the table and at the minute
the option that labour would choose
which is a customs union means that the
EU would only accept that if you also
accept freely we know the two options
that are on the table there as a result
of two E's amazing ago she a ting style
which have set out was completely wrong
from the out
what we've set out is that we understand
that free movement will end as we exit
leo that's non-negotiable and we want to
have a robust immigration system that
puts our economy first but we're also
saying that we want to be part of a
customs union and have a deal that
secures the same benefits within the
single market that we currently have
including all of the rights and
protections we would have set out our
negotiations on that basis and I suspect
would be in a very different place with
the European Union today
now you're announcing as shall a
business secretary plans today to have a
third of workers on company boards can
you just explain what that's all about
how it would work well I think certainly
over the last eight years we've seen a
culture of short-termism in many of our
boardrooms and that's underlined by
stagnant productivity stagnating wages
are not due to return to pre-crash
levels till at least 2020 - and we think
it's right that workers themselves who
have an interest in the long term
direction of particular companies have a
stake in that company that they're heard
within the boardroom they understand
what happens on the shop floor
how productivity can be increased how
efficiencies can be made and they should
be able to speak quite freely to all the
members of the board in order to pursue
that long term strategy of a particular
company you and the show and the Shadow
Chancellor joint Donna have been on a
bit of a mission haven't you to kind of
woo businesses I mean is this really
going to go down very well with the
businesses and the companies that you
need to convince and that labor is going
to be a credible government that won't
have a negative effect on the economy
the vast majority of businesses respect
their workforce and it's a bit of a
misconception to say that they don't and
I suspect that they will want to involve
workers more especially if it means
increasing productivity and and you know
improving the company's long-term
direction overall it's not taking away
powers from all the directors it's
merely allowing those workers to have a
voice at the boardroom table to be able
to help make those decisions that
improve a company overall are you
relaxed I'm interested in your answer to
this Wanek are you relaxed as someone
once said about people becoming filthy
rich as long as they pay their taxes
well we don't have people paying their
taxes at the moment and that's one of
the the common kind of issues that comes
up on the doorstep in my constituency
most people are fed up of doing the
right thing
working hard paying the taxes businesses
are fed up of doing the right thing
paying their taxes and if people do pay
their taxes are you relaxed with how
much wealth that they can create well I
think there's been a problem certainly
you know in this government's ten-year
and you know across you know our economy
overall over the last thirty years where
we've seen wealth you know accrue in the
hands of a small percentage of people
and that's not just to do with taxation
that's to do with the whole range of
economic policies and issues and what we
want to do as a Labor Party and we'll
set this out at the conference this week
is to rebalance that economy so it's not
just about how much people are taxed but
it's about making sure that people
actually have the ability to earn more
and businesses have the ability to
generate more profit so that they can
pay their staff more it's about
realizing the economy nicely sized start
there now one other thing that I was
keen to talk to you about is a skies
campaign to try and make leaders debates
have been effectively you know in
election times we want to see an
independent commission set up to try and
work out who should be in those debates
and how they should happen is that
something that you would support I think
is I think it's interesting the point
about the Independent Commission because
many of our members you know would argue
that certain you know
outlets would you know favor one
particular party or and other so it's
important to make sure that these
leadership debates are fair and it's a
good opportunity for you know people
across Britain to hear about the
policies from particular parties without
the spin you know without the rhetoric
and one last question for you and the
NEC the National Executive Committee
about EV labor decided that there should
be two deputy leaders at the Labor Party
one of course is Tom Watson the other
they say should be reserved for a woman
it's not something you'd consider
running for not even thought about what
if I know well I don't now what sure
what's a quick thought I don't I can't
to sign up what I haven't Islands
haven't thought about it I'm very very
busy dealing with business energy and
industrial strategy and I like that very
much and I'm sure that that's going to
keep me busy for a long time okay